在下半场开场之前我们先揭晓一下我们今天的神秘嘉宾其实我们今天的神秘嘉宾就是咸鱼的客户当团队进入负责人宗欣然后宗欣现在应该已经在那个在在脉上的那个宗欣能给大家打一个招呼吗嗨大家好我是宗欣能看到吗对可以可以好的那个也很感谢宗欣因为宗欣确实比较忙然后就有时间
对对对然后他也有时间出了时间来跟我们一起来聊一聊我们今天第二个部分的一些问题还是比较有意思的然后我们今天的这个第二个环节是这样的就我们可能在这个聊的过程中随时可以看那个直播间的问题大家如果有问题的话我们觉得还比较有意思我们就会直接选出来进行讨论那我们今天还是先讨论一下我们上一场讨论过的一个话题啊就如果比如说有的同学对嫌疑团队是比较感兴趣的那肯定会好奇这个问题
那这个问题的话我觉得新苏或者中兴回答都可以就比如说咸鱼的这个记录氛围是怎么样去打造的可以大概聊一聊吗这个我来说一下可以可以我先讲技术氛围是怎样的其实我作为一线开发实际上感受还是比较深的我觉得第一点就是整个团队还是以好奇心来驱动做事情比如说
行業內的一些新的特性比如說一些廠商與什麼發布大家可能都會去主動去了解但比如說之前的元宇宙其實也有同學分享過其實我覺得這就是一個好奇心驅使大家去做這個氛圍另外呢也是作為技術團隊作為業務業務團隊我們開始逐漸的去用業務去把技術去影響業務這我覺得是很難的
但是我们也有一些尝试比如说有同学在最近去以技术的视角去了解进品比如说我的一个图片上传的是什么样的分辨率呈实的是什么样的格式实际上是以技术的视角去看了这个然后做一个统计做一个文档然后去反向输出给PD然后PD呢实际上平时估计PD也会有做
同行業的APP的體驗那可能它忽視了一個技術的視角就是你這個的行為去反向去推動產品這個是我們進行一個比較好的一個趨勢吧這也是一點第三個我覺得我們團隊是越來越注重細節的之前確實有一些體驗上的問題但是大家是越來越重視去主動去解決這個問題
是怎麼打造的我也講一下我的觀察雖然我只是整個觀察我來打造我覺得是整個像PL整個比如全臉大家主動會去點贊比如說有些發現給大家分享都會去鼓勵啊不會去說你做這個有什麼不太好啊都會鼓勵大家去做一些調研什麼這些就會形成一個好的氛圍
第二个呢其实我们现在分享是和到了周会里不强制分享大家有一个分享就可以自己去报名然后也不限制任何主题比如说自己是业务上遇到什么问题或者说最近有什么发现都可以在周会里面去交流不强制反而大家还是比较主动去做一些讨论的而且周会上讨论是非常开放非常热烈效果还是非常好的第三个呢
我们其实每天都在过雨晴这也是为什么对大家体验上有问题的其实我们都会去跟呢对整体我观上下来是这样嗯我明白所以所以我理解来就是整个咸鱼团队的话就是比较一个是还是比较愿意去尝试一些新的东西的就整个氛围然后大家也是鼓励去做一些新东西的尝试然后同时呢对我觉得这个从
技术影响业务好像我觉得好像这个还满下阿里的因为我们之前我之前也在阿里嘛所以我们的整个风格也是说我们是希望技术团队不单单是说就是只是做一些业务需求但我们也希望从我们的角度能去给业务返向的一些帮助对然后对我觉得这个问题其实刚好就可以引申到我们今天的第二个问题啊因为按照辛素现在讲的就是我们其实是比较
整个咸鱼团队是比较喜欢去做一些新鲜事件尝试包括对把大家对于整个Flat这个长寿就也是比较勇敢的对所以我就想问一下我们现在的第二个问题啊对因为我们知道咸鱼确实也是国内比较早的这种大的团队去用这个Flat所以我这个问题应该是可能需要忠心来回答一下就是在当年是什么那个契机让咸鱼去决定拥抱这个Flat嗯那OK大家能听到吗对
ok 如果能听到的话那我开始了就是我觉得是这样就第一个其实起源其实还是蛮简单的一个契机其实在17年的时候左右的时候我们其实在看见事情就是17年前咸鱼的整个业务发展坦白说都还是比较好它是一个集团内部的幅画的项目从14年开始到17年都是一个比较这个
除以高增长的一个趋势就很快到了一个千万两级的规模但这个过程中其实管理团队一直在想一个问题就是当业务一个团队除了业务打胜仗然后大家可以分一点钱以外这个能给团队留下的是什么什么东西是大家更高层次的一个要求或者说这个上面
就是大家除了在做業務以外這個對我們人的關注或者更更OK然後這個過程中能做哪些事情對大家這個長期有更有更多的長期價值那這個是當時我們在思考的問題那基於這個問題我們就在想說我們怎麼能去打造一個這個
团队的品牌然后能让这些每一个到显于一个团队的同学他们能在技术上有成长能在能建立他们自己长期的这个技术品牌和自己的这个行业口碑那更多还是以人出发去看这个事情那但是看这个事情的过程中呢又不能说我们今天是完全是建什么东西做什么东西然后完全是这个为了创新而创新所以这过程中其实我们需要去看一下就我们到底要解决什么样的问题那这个基于这个
解决问题的奇迹我们会发现当时的团队的人相对的规模会相对比较少那我们也当时也在尝试说我们通过Wix或者通过一些其他的这种跨端的这种技术去解决我们的人效的问题那这个是一个相对比较实际的确定性的问题那这个过程中我们觉得我们只是单纯觉得现有的市面上的这些技术可能实现的不是特别好也有很多不管是意识性的问题也好还是这个
研发的配套工具不友好的问题也好还是性能的问题也好所以我们就去整个行业去找类似的技术这个找类似技术的过程中刚才又回到说我们其实本账还是希望大家能成长对吧那说实际一点就是我们希望这个过程大家在学习这边技术或者说长期用这边技术以后大家能提升大家在市场上面的技能力
因为最后还是市场说话我觉得这个还是相对对大部分一线同学这个是相对比较重要的一件事情那如果急于这件事情去做呢我们就决定还是要用第一个要用一个开源的标准技术因为如果你不是用一个开源标准技术你是用个必原的技术那很多场景下面可能它你没法没法在其他的这个公司或者说或者说在这个行业内大规模使用我觉得这个是有一个问题的然后另外一个就是这个用标准的技术以后
背后对行业的救业价值还有个人品牌的外业也有帮助完全是基于人的角度去考虑这件事情同时我们去看到技术本身带来的一些TN的提升和
和效能的收益那继续这两个收益我们去进行的尝试当然我们也不是一下子就去做了这个决定啊我们从17年开始到19年我们在验证的过程中其实花了三年的时间我们才验证了这个东西我们觉得差不多能上然后我们才开始逐步的上你一直到大概在20年21年开始这个大规模的运用然后
形成一个效能的拐点我们其实也是在长期布局做一件我们验证完以后我们认为正确的事情这个就是我们当时的整个的起源和过程起源其实挺简单的过程其实现在说是这样说但是实际上我们逐渐遇到了挺多的坎坷和不确定性的这个过程中我今天就不处详细说但我可以分享两个我自己背后思考就第一个
我們怎麼樣去做基礎創新就是做基礎創新的過程中其實有很多阻礙對這個這個過程我估計大家如果只是看這個咸魚做出來的這個最後的那個結果那可能這些阻礙可能都沒有看到就是我覺得有一句話我覺得可能可以送給大家就是我們要做一些正確而非共識的事情
就很多时候今天大家会问我这个flutter我刚刚看的大家说flutter未来发展方向是什么样子然后客户端费来发展方向是什么大前端费来发展方向是什么是个里头其实很多时候是没有共识的但是我觉得从我自己的经验或者说我自己目前的这个认知的这个层面上面来讲我自己有一些我认为是正确的方向且这个过程大家可能
不一定都買單這個方向那比如說我們後面可以討論一下我覺得這個大前端的方向以及客戶端的容器化這件事情我覺得是有意義和有價值的它可以幫助我們的客戶端整個的這個在整個在未來的中端的布局上面更快就是它的可疑之性本身就能帶來我們未來中端的能力前移那我認為這件事情是正確且目前來講我覺得可能是非共識的就是未來如果我們今天用極限的眼光去看或覺得可能
未来扣端就是一个容器 那这个也是有可能的啊 那我们今天去类比这个服务端的容器的这个容器化的这个这个这个视角去看服务端的这个这个这个 brownity我还有它的这个容器的一些标准啊我觉得这个这个我只能说我不能说百分之百未来是那个样子但我说我认为扣端容器化是一个方向所以我们今天我觉得需要去长期的呃
推进类似的未来可能成为荣幸化标准的这一类技术的落地这个是正确而非共识这个过程中可能需要自己的长期投入和在这个过程中其实有一些挫折或者说这过程中有一些反复有一些体验不了位当然也会被大家质疑然后我们再去把一些体验的问题再解决这个其实还是需要一个长周去解决的这个是正确而非共识另外一个方向是说
刚才讲做正确的事情吧那另外一方向我认为说怎么怎么叫做正确的事情那我我觉得不一定在每个时间内都知道自己会去做这个这个什么是正确的事情但一般情况下大概能知道什么是不正确的事情或者说知道自己不应该做什么我觉得这个是比较重要的那这个过程中我们在选择技术创新的时候我们也希望说我们做一些
就比方说我们今天我也不太希望说团队去造比较低水平的轮子那如果我们今天的很多的Native的能力其实集团内已经有或者行业内已经有我们的这个合作伙伴也好还是我们的这个训练团内已经做得非常好的我建议大家其实直接使用的我其实不太希望在这个上面再花更多的时间去去卷这件事情而反而是说我们
去解决自己的目前的痛点然后我们去看到今天在我们讲断测容计划这个之间事情上面还有很多门卡没有解决的部分我们怎么去做一些攻击和突破那我认为这个可能是更正确的那这个这个这个这个这个就是呃背后的思考啊大概大概是这个样子对嗯明白非常感谢我觉得那个中心讲了很多啊就甚至可能远远超出了我们今天
问的这个问题对我觉得其实我简单理解一下吧就其实呃中心讲这个点可能也是就这个问题我觉得中心的回答应该是可以给很多的呃比如说这种team leader的角色是能够给到一些帮助的就是因为我们做team leader的话我从我的理解我现在也是在做团队负责人嘛那确实我们一方面可能整个技术肯定是要为业务服务的然后这是我们要向上负责但是
我们其实也是要向下负责对吧就我觉得其实中芯在选情这个flutter的时候其实我只能说从我的理解来说我觉得中芯确实是一个很负责任的听力的因为至少是对下属是很负责的因为在选这个方向的时候其实等于是在业务和这个大家的机会成长上找了一个结合点一方面就是能让整个团队包括因为整个flutter我们觉得可能比较关注的是效能方面那在效能方面其实
给这个团队就是给向上也能有一个好的一个结果那对于佛拉的这个新技术呢又让下面的一线的同学有更多的机会去尝试新技术我觉得确实还是蛮蛮蛮难的对我觉得中间肯定也是经历了很多的困难对然后刚才他讲的后面那个部分的话我觉得是一个我本来我们可能在后面要问的问题啊对我觉得那你先不管吧我们先再去讨论一下下一个问题啊我不知道我的理解对不对
对 但我觉得这个经验对于这种V的来说还是有很好的一个参考价值OK 然后我们准备一下第三个问题这个问题其实可能是想问新宿的然后也是说可能是一线的开发同学比如说如果有的同学可能想去可能比如说想去往新宿这个方向走那新宿的一些经验可能会对大家有参考的意义所以萌萌的这个问题
那新宿可以方便回答一下嘛就是现在你专注的领域以及说你是怎么去构建这块的一个技能树的首先呢我在做flat之前实际上是OS开放之前也做过一些动作化的事情后来的其实来到写运之后其实一直游走在flatwork 我觉得目前专注的领域其实也在flatwork至于如何构建这个技能树呢
第一个作为业务团队首先平时不能放过一些问题就比如说我们一些不记得的嵌套为什么这样嵌套有问题那么一般呢大家可能会去寻找另一种可能展示出来就好了我就不去管为什么这个有问题啊我觉得这是一点就是大家平时在业务开发中啊不要放过问题这是一点第二点是多看一下原码像Flatts开源什么代码你都能看到
看圆码实际上可以让自己进攻的非常快第三个呢我觉得大家可以把Flat官方的扣给拉下来拉下来做什么呢可以右键Blame看一下他们的请教的一些思路的改进这个我觉得非常有用你可以跟着他们的思路去为什么那么改而且他们一般可密的信息里面会有一个链接家会可以看到对应的e-show啊如果你对某一个
威记者感兴趣其实可以进去看一下其实还是有很多可以发现的大致就是这个三点我觉得OK我觉得那个新宿分享这个思路还是蛮就是蛮蛮蛮程序源的对而且我我看那个因为包括今天我们直播间也有很多同学在问嘛就是比如说新宿今天分享的这个这两个开源这两个项目就是什么时候开源大家其实肯定也是想着说去通过看我们这些开源的代码然后去学习新宿可能
包括可能嫌疑的同学在写这代码的一个思路好的 行然后大家如果说是也是想再往FLA往这个方向走的话也可以去做一个参考对我们在聊第四个问题我们先插一个问题吧因为我们看直播电影很多同学问就是因为刚才嫌疑也讲到就是嫌疑其实是一个比较拥抱新技术的东西吧因为昨天应该是今天凌晨吧就FLA的3.0刚刚发布了我不知道
我们可不可以聊一聊就是大家对vlog3.0的一个大概的理解以及现在的一个思考的东西给大家聊一下嘛hello那先说我还是我来我简单讲一下我我我看到的他其实有一点是一起聊一下好了桌面桌面平台的一些知识吗我定支持了各个桌面平台这一点另外的是有些性的修复比如说
當區這個雖然我沒有太理解但是修復了一些問題其中呢就就一個我們同事啊他點到了一個我們是一個arcfix就是我們同事非常強的一個人另外的另外呢我不太記得 sorry整體呢我大概說到那個後面段其實我們閒語言
最近也在做一个东西,也是桌面端的东西,那时候会接触到对应的东西。而且我们今天决定也在讨论那个FFI的事情,在桌面端可能会非常有用做到这个事情,其他的暂时没有。反正我看来是这样的3.0的话,一方面可能还是适配吧,就是适配之前的一些包括LS4的一些
体验问题,还有一些像M1的处理器,这个我记得它是有些适配的,然后另外一个就是它主要的变化,我认为可能还是对像其他的中端的,比如说这个折叠手机,然后像我们的Desktop就是桌面端的支持会更多一点,所以这部分的话
我當然我也看了一下顧外奧的我沒有完全看完就看了一部分顧外奧今天除了前面在講AI和AI在搜索還有在什麼地圖還有國際道客上面的應用以外其實他還提到的其實我認為他有更多的新的中端比方說他用一個 Hub然後還有一些可能後面還有一些眼鏡對吧還有一些其他的一些中端的介紹我認為
如果他多中端的本身的试配,肯定对整个技术的生命率会更强一点。今天回到闲于本身关注的问题,当目前为止会关注很多。今天在细节上,大家可能觉得不是太大问题的地方,但是我们会认为,今天我们如果为一个
大级千万辆级或者说上一辆级的未来的这样的一个IP去做准备或者说我们为其他的更多的端比如说派的比如说折叠评的这些新的中端去做准备的话其实还是有很多问题没有被解决的比如我就举一个例子我们现在的红河战的方案我看大家刚才直播我看了一眼可能也有人在问红河战的方案本身今天其实还是有问题的
就是混合站的方案里头我们今天大部分情况下我们用混合站是用单引擎对吧单引擎带来的问题就是我们今天其实真正在派的上面我们如果做派的分屏或者我们做折叠屏的这个支持的情况下其实是很不好的那这个带来了另外一个问题是我们今天其实真正想迁移到我们说未来要做端策的容器化对吧我们要把这迁移到这个新的这个desktop这端那这个上面其实也是有这个这个这个这个明显的进入平静了
所以我們今天其實更關心的是說我們怎麼能做到多頻的這種設備的支持多頻設備支持背後主要其實是多引擎的支持就是混合戰從單引擎到多引擎的支持那多引擎支持更多其實是需要改造我們的一些flutter引擎上面的一些技齒來保證我們在代碼能在SOA的共享的同時
我們還能保證我們的內存水位是相對比較低的然後寫基本上可以支持我們現有的這種開發方式就是我們在開發方式不大變的情況下我們能做出單引擎到多引擎的切換那這個過程中我們希望最後可能切換的過程中我們表現
我们在手机上我们就用一个引擎那我们的整个的水位还有这个我们的这个IsoLate之间的因为大家都跑在一个IsoLate上面他的这个通信的这个都没有问题然后他性能也很好但比方说我们今天在PAT上面或者我们在未来的MACOS上面如果今天有这个
端上的就是中端上面的咸鱼的话,那我们希望它可能会有多个屏幕,多个界面,然后每个界面上面它是独立运行在自己的solite上面,然后且整个能存水位也不要过高,而且独立solite
之间的一些数据的通信因为你原来的设计里面如果我们现在什么都不改的话它在独立的solid里面互相之间通信是要通过接口去通信的它不能共享一些东西我们怎么能改到它还能共享一些内容我们尽量不用改我们现在的代码这个是我们现在要关注的这个也在flutter
二年的Romag裡面其實他其實提到了他其實提到了如果仔細看的話他其實提到了我們正在做這樣的實驗我們可能會先在我們的PAD上面去做一些應用但這個可能改動量相對還表達所以這個是我覺得FLA3上面可能現在比較關注的就是它可能對中端多龍彈支持本身我覺得對它
它长期的生命力一定是有帮助的这个上面我们关注的可能比较说我们本身的混合站上面的这个目前的使用我也认为它不是最优的它理论上来讲它应该是能支持多引擎且这个水位是比较低的且在上层的研发的这个视角上面大家的代码机量不要改这个是一个然后另外一个就是可能我记得他刚刚新宿讲了很多这个性能改进的部分也就是说明说今天他在很多性能的
性格上面还是有一定平静的所以这个上面我们其实也在这个集团其实也在整体在关注这件事情对包括内网也有同学前一段时间我记得官方官方的那个就是一栋阿里一栋一栋有一个有一个记录账号也在讲到他的这个替换斯格亚的一个新的实验性的宣言工具对这个也都做了一些分析所以可能我看到就这两个
新改进和desktop的桌面段或者说更多中央的支持吧对明白但我觉得我给个建议就是大家如果今天是自己玩玩我觉得的话可能3.0OK的但是我觉得以我们自己的经验来看如果今天要在生产环境里大规模部署的话我建议稍微等等我们今天目前的版本还在用2.5.3的版本其实真正要在整个
就是这个生产专应用其实对这个整个轮延性要求也好还是对一些能力的这个知识也好其实还是要求比较高的所以不能随便签签的过程其实还是成本有一些大对明白明白我懂对于这种新版本的升级其实小船队的话还是风险确实可能厚不住对然后对我刚才看到还有一个问题就是有一个朋友就这个影视发车的朋友问的一个问题就是说
这个核心业务上不敢去上这个优化就要怎么去推动啊就是这种就FLA的这种东西我不要理解对不对就是FLA在核心业务里面去推然后又不敢推这个就是要怎么去推动因为我理解嫌疑是不这样的经历的吗对不知道这个方方面回答我觉得这个问题得分解一下就是核心是说其实我我我既然来这边或者说
我经常会被别人问一个问题就是我怎么才能在这个场景下用这个辅拉台这个技术对吧其实我觉得这个有点本没道理的就我们得清楚一下就今天咸云在那个场景下面刚才其实也讲了我们其实除了人成长以外其实它是有实际的应用场景的就是我们团队人的这个首先人的规模相对比较少然后我们的人才的结构上面更多是以扣单为主
我们前端更少是一个扣端为主的一个计数站另外一个就是扣端为主计数站里头我们的安卓的同学更多一些iOS同学其实反而更少一些加速了我们在这个计数的选用上面所以我们认为这个技术在这个阶段能解决我们的问题所以你其实问这个问题之前可能要想一想就是Flutter在你的核心业务上面到底减没解决你的问题是
它能带来长期的增量价值还是说我今天可能试一试我也不太确定那这个可能要搞清楚如果如果如果我们当时其实改了这个基础连络包括到现在为止我们的大量的基础连络现在确实就是投入一端开发然后保证了我们整个的这个交付效率那这个上面我们的维护成本后期的维护成本因为规模代码量也比较大那代码量大的情况下我们的
維護成本其實相對還是比較低的那這個上面我們認為我們有一些實際的收益那這個我覺得可能要想一下那如果你確定這件事情是ok可以做的那我覺得你可能就要考慮一個問題第一個你要摸底一下今天在核心主鏈路上面的業務它需要什麼能力
它需要符文本能力,它需要播放器的能力,它需要图片库的一些基础能力它的性能能不能达标,这些东西可能细化的一条一条都列完以后,你都分析完以后,你有一个文档,然后去逐个check,然后都搞定的情况下我建议才上我觉得这个可能更容易让业务区得到业务知识吧
你可能不能做一个有损的这个开发我们可能还是要保证业务的这个基本体验的情况下我们把它上线然后在这个过程中持续投入那保证最后能拿到那个手艺因为我们在任何新技术的前期的投入过程中其实它的效率其实是下降的就开始是效率一定是下降的它是一个就是叫就跟那个对勾的形状
它是先下降再上升那你前期的那个成本一旦付出它的依稀性成本付出完以后你后续可能才能等到它上升那很多团队其实在这个阶段它可能没有这个条件它没有等到上升它可能觉得这个东西就没用了就把它干掉所以这个可能也是需要
所以总结一下第一个如果你今天要做这件事情你可能要先问一下自己这件事情在主点路上面的价值大不大我举个例子如果今天是像抖音这样的业务它其实它的业务的形态也比较成熟它的主点路上面已经是个评为主然后主要都是一定给页面为核心去做的研发它的核心能力上面我认为它端上的核心能力一定不是这个或者说组色它整个研发的一定不是效率问题
它的開發也很多然後它的這個開發上面因視頻的底層能力的優化更多一些那這個上面本身它就是要分鑽做的那這件事情我覺得就不合適那但是如果不是這樣的業務我們今天表示是一個典型電商的場景我覺得非常合適還有一些像這個我們講土地的土地的一些這個場景我說非常合適表單然後這個這個大量的圖片大量的這個像這個我們的
有部分的符文本和视频我觉得这个就非常合适这个可以大量的解决你的问题所以本质上还是这个问题是什么这是第一个 第二个就是如果你今天确定已经要解这个问题了你一定要把前期的记录调研我觉得还是要搞清楚就是我们到底需要什么能力可能12345勾完勾完以后我们都有完整的DEMO避缓然后可以搞定然后我们再聚上这件事情我觉得这个上面的主意就会更少一点大概是这两个建议吧
好的我不知道能不能回答到直播间里面这个朋友然后我们先直播间的问题我们先停一下然后我们先过一下下来问你这个问题是给新宿的就如果想成为一个flat公司因为我理解你现在就是一个flat的工程师那需要准备些什么样的东西呢我觉得第一个还是要有用我固的native的基础这个我觉得是不可以避免因为有一些场景还是需要native的基础比如前面我分享的
图片库实际上还是要内提不去做一些事情第二个我觉得是需要了解一下Flat的基本原理其次呢要在对Flat的服务幕可有一些了解包括官方一些demo要去熟悉第三个呢是data的语言特性比如说它的invent log比如说它的non-safety都要去做一个了解第四个呢我觉得是工具的问题要对Flat原生的工具做充分的利用这个释放工本
对整体就是这四个点哎对方便问一下就你学就是这个东西你在过就是学习的过程中大概花了多长时间学习的50来咸鱼的时候是自己体验了一下整个达特的一个官方的demo然后去移植到我们之前做的一个app里整体就是从这个入门的啊好吧那其实等于就是没有其实没有专门学习嘛可能就是在项目时间的过程中就
把这些东西都学会了对好的这也是一个经验就我觉得其实确实对于很多这种新技术来说你与其说去花很长时间去把整个样子完全看完可能更多的还是说找到一个实用的场景然后去编做编学可能整个效率会更高一些ok对我看很多直播间同学在说了就是也很多是编编编做编学的ok好的那
刚才这个问题就是我们刚才讲可能宗庆已经讲过了就是对吧就你有哪些比较深入的前沿的研究我不知道这个问题我们是不是还要再聊一下我可以大概讲一下吧大概讲一下就是可能我们之前去年其实做了一些这个部分内容那这个部分内容的话分几项吧就第一个其实去年一年的成年里头主要其实还是要解决体验的问题我觉得我们在这个
或者说20年以后其实我们其实在享受这个flutter带来的那个效率的这个效能红利这个以外其实我们还是需要填很多坑的这个是我们必须要客观的这个反思和和和这个认识到这点的不是说我们今天什么问题都没有就是我们今天在很多体验上面包括今天在flutter的这个整个社区上面我觉得
也還是有一些能力的缺失的就是說很多能力其實是缺失的那今天這個坑還是要我們自己團隊去填嘛那我覺得這個上面我自己也面臨了一些這個業務上或者是說來自業務或者來自老闆挑戰我覺得這是很正常的那這個管理者其實是需要有這樣的第一個要相信自己做的這個在認為這件事情是正確的情況下我覺得要堅持一部分自己的決定然後並且在這個困難的程度上面
困难情况下去说服老板然后用我们的一些这个技术能力的这个实现来来来解决那个业务的问题那那这个过程中就是我们去年一年主要其实做的是填升级极限的建设还有人的能力的提升那我们去年一年的这个填升级上面主要围绕着像今天新宿讲的福恩本还有图员库还有一些这个跟接常课的一些结合啊我们做了很多这个
我們確實也有一些基礎的中間電的代碼的沉澱當然我們今年在做很多事情的過程中我們也要求我們要有CI我們要有測試用力我們這些東西要補清楚我們才能去做進一步的推廣我們今天已經在推進這件事情了然後剛才也講了在內部的走流程了
啊啊这图片库的问题这个也是为什么之前人说要放的那现在还没放的因为呃还是嗯一个是流程比较长然后再一个就是这个我们的这个要求其实也在过程中不断在呃再提高最自己的要求我觉得这是一个比较重要的事情啊然后嗯
然后另外一个是这个大弦端容器然后大弦端容器这个事情可能后续如果再讲到这个大弦端的时候我觉得再细讲吧就大弦端容器上面我们其实今天也在做一些尝试我们希望能让更多的前端同学进到这个福拉特生态里面这个我们会做一些尝试也有自己的一些容器的定义我们现在线上其实也在跑我们在验证看这个因为
剛開始做一部分所以我也不太想說這個大張旗鼓的講這件事情但我覺得這個事情對大前端未來的這個幾乎讓融合有幫助所以我們在做一些單身容器的事情然後另外一個就是剛才講的那個多頻帶來對應情的問題我們現在也在做嘗試個驗證現在有一些這個demo然後以及這個業務的遷移主要現在是面向派的大家還沒做完還在做這是體驗的提升那另外一個就是基建的
基建的能力的建设就包括我们之前的一些构建速度表慢那我们的FRADA代码包括插件代码三对来讲跟一般的工程来比还是非常多的我们插件可能有几十个那我们的这个构建的整个的时长也很长那这个过程中我们的构建速度然后怎么提升然后另外一个就我们把这个构建的能力怎么变成集团的插件
就给到集放用我觉得这个是一个比较重要的事情另外一个就是在这个基建的过程中我们开始就补充我们的CNN能力我们进行一些定期的core real和代码质量的设计跟大量包括代码质量的一些要求我觉得这个是对基建能力的一些提升最后一个是对人的能力的提升就是前几年我们更多的还是围绕说我们做一个
耍他的二环的开发二环开发是指说我们今天不碰引擎我们更多是在更上层去做应用开发我觉得这个事情是因为我们当时的能力限制我不得不承认我们19年的时候的能力跟今天的能力相比我觉得我们还回去看的话我们有很多能力其实是不足的然后这个过程中当然我觉得今天的团队能达到这样的
一个新的这个这个这个水平我觉得完全要归功于像这个新宿他们这些啊优秀的这个新一代的这个开发同学他们非常有激情然后有有有有好奇心他们也愿意在上面花花心思我觉得这样这些同学啊这个
推动了整个咸鱼的在Ferrata上面的能力的提升所以去年开始我们在Ferrata上面的PR显著增多然后我们的整个PR是整个集团的一半那我们的整个康徐比萨尔也是整个目前来讲我知道了集团的一个大头
所以我们团队有大量的这个有十多个contributor所以我觉得这个还是比较重要的就是可能之前就没有这么多可能之前就一两个那我觉得这个是团队真正开始在这个过程中有构建的专家有free market 层的专家有隐形层的专家每个人都在自己的领域能做出一些事情我觉得这个是我
怎么讲的就是感到非常骄傲的而且我觉得这件事情可能更多的真的是归功于这里面的每一个同学他们自己有对自己的要求然后反向形成了这样一个团队的文化我觉得这个是非常重要的所以这是去年一年的沉淀那面向未来如果我们今天再去看未来的一些
方向的話我會認為說第一個我覺得未來扣端的用極限的剛剛講用極限思維的方式去看我覺得扣端可能最終真的有可能就是個容器就是扣端在或者中端會有一個統一的容器在不同的中端設備上那這個統一的容器它會隔離掉今天在
在不同操系統上的一些特性那它的開發方式我認為應該跟遊戲的開發方式是一樣的就是今天你再去做很多這個這個三一大作的過程中還有一些這個非獨佔的這個遊戲的過程中大家其實都是用這個都是用跨平台的技術對吧本質上其實最早我們去中國去看QT或者去看瀏覽器怎麼出來就是跨平台這件事情本身就是個槓序
所以所以所以大家的目标其实还是希望说我们今天能做到我们为什么要做多套代码的部署或者说为什么要写多套代码这件事情这件事情本身就是不合理的就大家只是觉得好像说什么原生的体验怎么样但这件事情我认为如果你先能写一套代码也能达到那个原生的一样的体验那我认为这件事情不是更好吗那这件事情本身就是不合理的了所以我认为未来的这个方向扣端应该是有个容器标准的制定和
這個容器的這個這個對應的實現拿來支撐我們的單線端的實現的所以我們在這個過程中我們會跟華為或者是會跟一些其他的這個這個這個行業的同學們去交流去合作那我們未來肯定還是希望在更長久的未來我們想做一些這個國產自然的一些能力我覺得這個也是很重要的就是今天作為一個一個一個一個一個中國人吧我覺得
我們的國產軟件包括我們的這個這個行業的這個大量的能力其實還是還是基於國外的開源能這個軟件為主的我覺得我們能不能在我們這一代或者我們在下一代我們在有一些這個技能上面有些突破能幫助我們的國家建立一些這個核心的技術壁壘那可能可能這個東西我說話說並沒有那麼難或者說這個過程中這個
怎么怎么怎么说呢可能没有没有没有想象那么高大上但我觉得这个也是挺重要啊就是这个过程能让大家呃真正能不能为这个国内的社区或者说为国家做点事情我觉得这个也也也挺有意义的吧啊所以明天未来的话就是两个一个是容器码标准的制定和啊自然容器的实现啊另外一个自然容器实现但这个上面可能会涉及到后面跟鸿蒙或者跟一些其他的这个
这个国内商场的合作这个也不一定啊对对对我们我们也有一些这个在做的事情在这个可能今天也不展开了啊对对明白明白对我觉得宗庆刚才讲的这些部分其实可能后半部确实太传言非话太难但我觉得可能已经做到的一些事情对于一些已经在用flat然后可能想要往深圳去走的团队其实还是有很有参考意义的就刚才讲的那四个点
可能这四个方向比如说你这个团队可能已经在做Fla的然后想法有更深的研究那这四个方向上其实都是可以做一些更深入的探索好的那这个问题刚刚应该讲过了是不是我觉得刚刚问题好像那个中心已经打过这个问题了打前到你一个一个位置对对所以我们就我们就跳过吧对对对因为我觉得确实对那那下一个问题就是我问我们新宿的就是关于
这个提效的一个开发工具这个也可能是一线的再做flat的同学比较关心的就有没有什么可以提效的开发工具可以去推荐的啊这个其实没有新的了其实我还是强烈推荐flat的原生的这个EV12因为它真的很强不该90%多的一个场景首先呢比如说我们的flat它的flatinspector模块它可以直观的看到此问题比如说另外它可以
比如說有些模塊它一直在動畫刷新其實它會有一個顏色的標記你也可以看到那再比如說呢一個新同學剛接觸這塊業務那麼我不知道這個代碼不熟悉也可以透過這個模塊去比如說點擊某一個危機層那麼它就可以幫你定位到那個對應的代碼寫這個對一個新同學來接觸一塊業務其實非常有用另外呢比如說它的對性能的一些測試工具比如說流暢性內存的實際上它都有還有一些報答小
包大小台可以把你分析一下其实整体整个的开发的东西他基本上都有对其实就推荐还是推荐官方员是吗嗯明白可以哎这个有没有一些相关的资料就是可以就是新宿这边结束之后可以再去你发一下对因为可能讲的话或者比较简单整个都有讲哦都在都在文档里面是吧好的好的没问题然后我们这里还有一个同学问了一个问题啊我觉得这个可能是
可能就是想要去咸鱼或者说是想要去面与一些flat的岗位同学想问就是我们现在一般flat面试的话都会问什么问题啊这个是一个数字的帐号的同学问的就我们一般会问一些什么样的问题我觉得这样就第一个第一个可能我只能说咸鱼的这个角度上面我们的面试或者说我做面试官我可能更看重的是说你先解决问题的能力所以这个过程中
更多其实理论上来讲应该是你会什么或者说你在这个过程中你做过什么项目来来来来你是怎么解决这些问题的然后你的学习的这个路径是什么样子我觉得这个可能更重要那其实刚才也听到了说我们大量的同学其实招进来之前他是完全没做过flutter甚至他可能跨平台技术都没做过但是你像新宿
他们在做中文化的方案的过程中其实他也有一些思考对吧然后也会先上做一些代码的靠核然后看一下他的整个的风格他的工作的习惯也好代码的一些习惯也好其实包括在日常工作中之前的一些代码做也好我觉得这个可能更重要所以你如果说具体的一定要给我建议就是如果是来面咸鱼或者说来这个
我認為大廠的這個面試觀如果它相對有一些經驗的話它更多的可能會看你現有做了什麼事情
现在我做什么事情可能不会说我要专门问你一个你不知道领域或者说把你问倒我觉得这个是比较愚蠢的一般情况还是更多的是找你的优点对吧是欣赏你这个人我觉得这个可能更重要那另外一方面是说如果你今天一定要考说你做过flatter的话我会觉得可能分几种情况就第一个如果你今天是真的有线上的这个场景的话我觉得你可能要思考一下线上到底有什么问题
然后火候站上面你遇到过什么问题没有然后你的性格上面到底遇到什么问题然后这个上面的具体问题你是怎么分析怎么解决的这个很重要不一定是100%说一定要跟咸鱼的解决方案一样不一定对那你是怎么解决的你是怎么想这个问题的对吧然后我觉得这个是很重要的然后姐妹解过什么比较坑的问题那就代表你今天其实你的
解决的问题它是一个怎么讲的可以在生产环境应用的生产环境应用我认为跟做个demo完全不是一个难度做个demo其实非常容易但生产环境可能是它复达度的100倍我觉得这个上面还是不一样的所以在生产环境下面的实践我觉得肯定是很重要的不要生产环境的一些性能供基建的建设然后你的一些
包括面试完以后过程中的一些代码习惯我觉得这个都很重要最好是有一些想给他上面的一些自己带宝座我觉得这个是比较重要如果没做过呢其实也没关系没做过的话那你我觉得就是好奇心驱动那讲了那你了解不了解最近的一些我觉得新的动向对吧他的整个的眼睛的情况然后他的现在的问题和你自己玩过以后你自己玩完以后你对他的一些基本的判断我觉得这个都很重要明白对对
好的今天时间关键我们先往后过直播间问题我们先暂停一下然后对这个也是一个比较越涩问就是可能我们在直播间有很多朋友其实想有可能有一些问题就自己可能修复了一些问题然后也想给Vlad官方PR因为咸鱼这边基本上应该是有很多这样经验了然后我想问一下新宿这边就是怎么样去给Vlad这边去做官方的PR呢好的
給官方提一下整體的感覺就是官方其實非常嚴謹這也是我們今天3點已經其實他們也有提到5000多個PR如果他們通亂核的話可能整個Flat都已經跑不通了首先我覺得你做PR首先是有一個問題要麼有個feature對吧你可以先到他的一球裡面進行搜索假說這個有人提過那麼可以去看一下裡面有沒有什麼對應的討論有沒有什麼方案如果你有一個很好的話可以
可以直接走下一步假如說沒有這個儀秀那麼你就要去提出這個儀秀官方實際上給儀秀提了弄了很多分類你可以找到自己的儀秀所屬的分類新界儀秀裡面的一個點是說先給先描述一下你的問題其次呢在一個最簡的可以復現的一個demo還有就是你當前的blood環境再有呢最好可以錄一個頻
就是可以给官方人员一个很明显的一个能看到问题在哪里这个提出来之后呢一般官方人员会会给这个一修打标那个比如说一个P一级啊P0到P5之间如果这是一个重大的问题它一般是P0、P1、P2官方会优先去解决其次呢会解决P3的问题那P4和P5呢实际上就是P4他们认为是一个不太重要的一个办法
屁股的话是也是一个不太重要的一个feature一般的官方人员可能就没有多少时间去解决屁股和屁股的所以我也推荐大家去那些医术里面去找一些这个问题去研究一下这是打标的问题医术提出来之后呢会有人来回复做一个讨论其实同时可以报个一份巴特代码到自己仓库里面然后进行一个改动把自己做的修改
提上去之后还需要考虑到单册单册需要覆盖到自己的改动的点然后这个做好之后呢就可以提一下过去提过去之后关联这个英雄然后呢呃Google的机器人他会去首先去判断你有没有签署过他的contribute的协议假如没有他会提醒你先去签署我们签署完之后呢再去告诉机器人签完了机器人会
走下一步就是看你有没有对应的测试用力做完之后呢他会跑一些自动化流程来看一下有没有问题在这之后呢会有专门的人来review会会有些意见比如说你这能不能得分得可或者说做一些什么样的改动在之后呢假如说做都可以了我们就可以合进去当然合进去也不是说最终就进去了到主分之主分之之后flutter会定期会跑一些新的测试啊假如说他们定位到你这个
PIA有问题还是会回滚回滚继续做一些优化之后再合作对整体大概就这样明白啊我觉得这个其实这个体验还是蛮特别的因为可能大家很难有这样的一个一个经验对好的然后我看直播有没有什么别的问题ok好的然后呃这个问题要不我们就先跳过吧
对 就是因为今天时间的问题好像已经快9点半了对 我们现在跳过这个问题这个刚刚已经讲过了对 我们也跳过然后这是我们之前在群体讨论的时候就是有群体同学提的问题就是Fla的这个给编程上面带来的一个新的饭是和智慧有什么这个可以大概聊一聊吗其实我倒没有太多的研究但我觉得在我看完实际上还是声明式的
编程和命令式编程的一个差异像我们之前经常之前做OS嘛实际上是传统的一个命令式的一个编程大概从十年前左右把这种声明式的就开始流行起来的View React SwiftUI实际上都会都采用那个声明式的编程我觉得声明式的编程有很多优点比如说写起来方便搭起来大概页面实际上速度非常快
而且大家在看代碼的時候也非常容易理解當然它也有些問題就比如說在一些複雜的業務產能下可能它就表達能力就有限可能就需要像命名是靠攏在之前開發原生的時候其實是命名是開發我們在做一些組件化在做一些封裝的時候實際上也是把一個命名式的開發在下
生命式靠攏我覺得這兩個各有優勢但整個趨勢來說還是在像生命式的一個轉變然後變成範式的話它不得不提Facebook Redox其實我們在業務上實際上比較大的一個場景上都是重度使用Facebook Redox比如說我們的詳情頁比如說我們的發布比如說我們的交易實際上都在重度使用Facebook Redox它給我們其實
他的一些特点比如说深知复用啊实际上他的一个特点给我们业务开发中提效非常多比如说大家共同开发一个页面的时候每个component大家自己的5FReduce这种农线使我们开发的效率其实很多但是Redux其实也有一个问题就是门槛比较高对就是前期需要仔细去了解一下它一个概念概念比较多但是当你
把这个东西玩熟之后其实开发业务起来是非常顺畅的对高效的意义维护的对而且你比如说你一个页面我要去做某个模块的改动其实你可以在可能的直接就找到了然后要做什么刷新其实也非常容易能定位到嗯嗯但是的话曾经就这样好的好的行那我们今天聊一下最后的一个问题吧
这个可能也是很多想要用flutter的同学或者团队比较关心的一个问题啊就因为相于这已经在众都使用flutter吧那flutter有没有比较适用的场景以及说相应的一些收益这个可以大概介绍一下吗我说你简单讲一下我可能没那么深啊就是我觉得对于常规的abp你如果一个页面的业务逻辑非常复杂那么我觉得就可以用虽然现在很多
很多頁面實際上是把這個業務邏輯上移比如說移到焦慮層移到弧端但對於一些雷霆的頁面比較邏輯複雜的地方還是推薦於腐爛的首先我們在這種複雜場景下雙端的一致性邏輯一致性一定是有些差異的雙端的開發肯定會有一些理解不一致的地方另外是雙端實現的架構肯定也是有些差異的在後面做需求的眼睛的時候實際上都會變形
而flutter其實很好的避免這一點你一個人可以寫雙端的邏輯並且在UI的移植性上也是非常高的邏輯移植性也非常高就是不會出現說在某些特殊的場景下雙端表現是不一致的這是一點另外也是另外一點其實就是我覺得比如說一些多端的一些數學比如說2B的一些應用它可能不光是安裝OS可能有Windows Mac
一些诉求其实我觉得也是可以采用flutter嗯这是我的解好的好的非常感谢啊然后因为我看直播间有有的朋友在问啊就是关于这个呃就是动态化这个东西就是动态化热更新这个东西可以分享一下因为我觉得这个这个就有点太大了应该是比较大的一个topic所以这个同学问的话可能我们或者我们后续可以安排一起这样的一些
一个专门这样的分享对然后今天我们就不在直播间直接回答这个问题因为我觉得这个问题确实比较大是一个很大的一个项目然后因为这也是我们今天最后一个问题了嘛然后我们再看直播间有没有别的问题我们再最后回答一个问题吧然后再再结束今天的一个访谈环节ok 看一下我找一个问题啊稍等稍等我一下
哦 这有一个同学问了 就是混合开发的话 宿主工程编译时间久 这个要怎么去提效这个有没有一些相应的办法 就是新宿这边呃 这个我只能了解要不作为难嗯 呃 宿主工程编译时间久 是吧是是指的是说你的OK 那我觉得这个这个是这样的 就是
我们现在的或者我想一下我们现在的主要的一些这个常见的做法了常见的做法我们编译上面其实今天是分两段的对吧然后扣端这边这个flutter测的这个构建打包啊是一部分啊那他会产生一个比方说iOS变成他会产生firmwork然后上传到我们的这个
私有的report上面私有的report上面然后再去把它拉下来然后另外一部分是你的ls工程本身然后构建的速度现在分了两趴来讲这个事情其实我们会去看整个的构建速度第一趴刚才讲的如果我们是独立的flutter产物的构建速度的话它其实今天是有一个
大家知道它现在的新的混合模式的这样的一个构建的方式里面它其实有一个点ls或者点安卓的这样工程对吧它其实有一个你类似于一个你可以认为一个你主工程的T代的工程它的一些配置你要保证跟主工程是一致的对吧但你打包构建的时候你其实没有引用到那个
你的主工程所以主工程里面的代码是不参与编译的只是说你今天是有个站位的主工程帮你一起编译的这个过程中你的整个的构建速度就会变快
我觉得你可以看一下不管是官方的文章还是行业的一些构建优化的文章我觉得应该还是有的 咸鱼团队我觉得之前好像也有可以看一下我们公众号 我不太记得了 应该是有的本上是说我们今天用个站位的工程去构建我们的Flatte
來保證我們的Flatte這集的構建的速度然後另一集的構建速度裡面它就是原生的構建原生的構建裡頭呢無非就是說今天我認為安卓可能我們感覺把那個原碼改成A好像變化也不太大iOS的話呢就典型的就是把這個原碼打成Formock會快一些這個是一些常見的手段然後另外一個就是
定期我觉得可能要删些代码吧啊删些代码做一些这个你的这个引用的这个无效引用的治理这肯定是有效的啊然后还有一些就是一些呃就就乱七八糟挺细节的比方说我举个例子你温宁太多肯定也不行对吧你温宁编译的过程中会打大量的日子对吧嗯甚至可能这个这个这个这个呃上万或者是几十万行的这个这个这个都有
对 这就很恶心 因为它后面还有对战之类的 还有就是但是我觉得你可以分析一下 你可以分析一下那个那个那个那个编译的那个啊 因为比方说我举ELS为例这个它的编译的那个过程里面 它每一个产物的编译的那个市场企业有嘛 你可以看一下哪一个消耗的比较比较长 对啊 其实是有挺多办法的 那就是其实 那总结一下啊
Flata这边的优化里面或者说Flata构建产物的优化里面更多的是说你用站位的工程去做你不要直接用主工程跟它一起构建用站位工程跟它构建 点安卓 点安卓要保证这个站位工程的配置跟你主工程配置一样那这样的话构建了一个产物只要构建产物的速度会比较快那如果这个过程中又涉及到说构建完产物或者构建完插件直接插件一个一个要上传到你的这个
这个私有库私有的这个这个这个这个这个这个这个仓库上面然后再把它拉下来的这个动作的话那可能你的脚本里头要做一些并形化的这个动作还有一个过程就是打包的过程中打包的过程中你的环境你看你的环境打包机的环境能不能定制啊比如说你的打包机的环境里面你用用这个你的刀块里面能不能这个有一些这个安卓啊有一些这个发展环境其实啊已经在里面啊我觉得这个然后他的一些这个比如说
帕布在拉的过程中你这个构建了一次下一次再够他帕布本身是帕布开始对不对你只要你一个环境上面的一些这个开始啊给一些这个这个这个内容能也应用上来这个是我们最近也在做的那那那你的这个构建比方说你拉那个你不需要省去的你比方说拉那个法特原码环境然后拉这些东西的这个过程
這個是情生事件另外一個就是上傳過程中你如果是串形的話你把上傳變成併形了這個應該也能省不少時間這個是佛拉特測的這個性能的這個提升那內體不測的話其實有很多辦法內體不測的話我覺得你可能是要這個google一下或者bydo一下應該都能行啊我覺得google一下就可以了google一下裡頭還是應該有挺多方法絕境上應該也有啊
总体就是说减少编译的市场然后还有减少交叉编译的时间把无效代码的干掉反正会有一些这些内容明白好的非常感谢今天确实我们这个反弹发现还是聊了很久的然后我觉得也有很多确实比较干货的一些内容那还是最后还是最后再感谢新宿和中心这边给我们大家做一个分享